TO THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ECONOMY. MY NAME IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SABRINA CERVANTES AND I
SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE JOINED ME TODAY ON
THE DYESS WE HAVE VICE CHAIR
JORDAN CUNNINGHAM WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ED CHAU PHILLIP CHEN
JAMES RAMOS THREE OF US AND
SHARON QUIRK SILVA. THANK YOU
ALL FOR JOINING US TODAY HI WE
ARE ALSO JOINED BY OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT TOURNEY SIMONS AND
THE- CONSULTING WITH THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS POLICY UNIT
CHAIN GILLARD. JOINING US FROM
THE COMMITTEE OFFICES BENJAMIN
WERE HEIGHT THE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY FOR THE SOMEBODY JOBS
COMMITTEE. IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THE
CONFERENCE LINE BEN IS
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU AND HE
CAN BE REACHED AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWENTY NINETY.
TODAY'S AGENDA INCLUDES ONE
BILL THAT IS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
REYES. BEFORE WE BEGAN OUR BILL
PRESENTATION I NEED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF HOW THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME ORDER
WHERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN PERSON.
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRED. THAT MUST
BE WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFIED WHETHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR OUT OF
VIDEO. CONFERENCING SITE. IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MOUSE WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW ITEMS. WE'RE EXCUSE ME WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TO TESTIFY TODAY
FOR THE PUBLIC ROOM. ROOM FOUR
THREE SEVEN. WE HAVE A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND LIMITED
NUMBER. OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACE SCENE. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE SCENE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITOL FOR
THOSE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFYING
TO BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
I WATCHED YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. ARE IN
ADDITION THERE WILL BE. YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME
THOSE WITNESSES WHO ARE MAYBE
USING ONE OF OUR REMOTE TO HELP
TESTIMONY STATIONS EXCUSE ME
LOOKING ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
IN OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH YOUR TESTIMONY LIVE.
AND OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
AND ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS.
FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATOR.
TELEPHONE SERVICES WERE YOU CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE LINE.
FOR THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
JOBS WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN IF YOU'RE
CALLING AND PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO AT THE BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PART
HOW TO BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST ON YOUR SMARTPHONE
DEVICE. TO REDUCE ANY SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE A ANY
PROBLEM WITH THE MOTTO PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2090 AND
THEN WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE COMMITTEE IS ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE%
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE MAY
NEED TO LIMIT HOW ON THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN FOR EACH BILL.
AS WE ARE IN A TIGHT HEARING
SCHEDULE TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WOULD NOW LIKE
TO THANK. ALL THE LEADERSHIP
AND RULES COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORK DILIGENTLY TO ALLOW US TO
BE HERE TODAY AND HAVE A SAFE
RETURN. TO THE CAPITOL. AS
NOTED TODAY. WE HAVE ONE ON
FILE. THAT'S ITEM ONE A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN RELATED TO
THE PILOT PROJECT. AT THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM. I
WILL THE CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
FORMALLY ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SHARE CERVANTES HERE SHARES OF
UPDATES HERE VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM. QUESTOR CUNNINGHAM
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHECK OUT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHANT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAN HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PORT SILVA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
HERE. MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU MEMBERS WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AND
WE'RE NOW READY TO BEGIN A
REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS I MISTER
VICE CHAIR MAY ASK YOU TO TRY
THIS HEARING SO THAT I MAY
PRESENT MY BILL. THANK YOU.
TAKE A SEAT OR SPOT THE GAVEL.
JEVER YOU'RE MOST COMFORTABLE
WITH. THANK YOU TODAY WE ARE
HEARING AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
RAYOS RELATING TO THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE CONTRACT
EDUCATION CENTERS- BEFORE THE
CHAIR BEGINS HER PRESENTATION
ON THIS BILL PLEASE LET ME
AGAIN GIVE EVERYONE NOTICED
THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW
OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO GET IN
THE QUEUE. AND ONCE AGAIN THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR. THREE SEVEN. HUTCHER
CERVANTES PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ESTABLISHED A PILOT
PROJECT TO SUPPORT THE
ENHANCEMENT OF A REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK WHICH
CAN WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
WORK FORCE PARTNERS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK OVER EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANT CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
FILED IN CALIFORNIA. BETWEEN
THE DATES OF MARCH FOURTEENTH
AND AUGUST FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY MANY OF THE INDUSTRY
SECTORS MOST IMPACTED DURING
THE PANDEMIC ARE NOT EXPECTED
TO RETURN PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS
OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS INCLUDING
BUSINESSES AND HOSPITALITY
ACCOMMODATION AND TOWARDS A
TOURISM SECTORS. EVEN THOSE
INDUSTRIES SECTORS THAT ARE
ANTICIPATED TO RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY MANY LOWER SKILL JOBS
WILL BE PERMANENTLY REPLACE OR
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED THROUGH
AUTOMATION AND E. COMMERCE
BUSINESSES. AND BUSINESS MODELS
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED NEGATIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS DUE TO THE PANDEMIC ARE
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WITH
LIMITED EDUCATION AND TRAINING
BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN LEVERAGES ITS
EXISTING PROGRAMS IN PLACE IN
COMPTON COMPETENCIES TO RESPOND
TO THESE KOBE NINETEEN
UNEMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES QUICKLY
AND HELP GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE TO-
FOLKS WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SURE CERVANTES MISTER
MODERATOR UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
DEANNA CRAY BILL PAULA JAZZ IF
I MISPRONOUNCE THAT NAME WITH
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATE TRAINING CENTER AT
SAMBAR AND IN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE. THIS GRAVY-
YOU CAN BEGIN. HI MY NAME IS HE
HAD A GREAT DEAL AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN CORPORATE
TRAINING AND TECHNOLOGY NUMBER
IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. I HAVE TEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND CONTRACT
EDUCATION AND I AM EXCITED AND
THRILLED TO TESTIFIED TODAY.
REPRESENTING THE STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL COLLABORATIVE.
WE SUPPORT EIGHT AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN AS WE BELIEVE IT IS
CRITICAL TO ACCELERATING
CALIFORNIA ACT NOT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY BY PROVIDING OUR LOCAL
FAMILIES ESSENTIAL JOB DON'T
MAKE ENDS MEET. THE HOBBIT
NINETEEN FIFTY. CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND WORKFORCE
DISPLACING MILLION. CONTRACT
EDUCATION UNITS ARE THE
BUSINESS PARTNER AREN'T AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND
PROVIDE NOT FOR CREDIT RAPIDLY
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. AND
WORKFORCE UPSKILLING RESKILLING
AND RETRAINING. CONTRACT
EDUCATION UNITS RELY ON GRANTS
AND CONTRACTS SUCH AS
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANL AS
THEY ARE CURRENTLY. UNFUNDED
DIVISION OF THE COLLEGE DURING
THE COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
CONTRACT EDUCATION UNITS WERE
ABLE TO ATTEND THE IN PERSON
TRAINING VIRTUAL TRAINING FOR
EXAMPLE IN APRIL AND MAY SAMBAR
DINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
DELIVERED ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE BURKE FULL
TRAINING HOURS. EIGHTY THREE
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTION
COMPANY. AB FORTUNE FIFTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROJECT TO
CREATE A REGIONAL BUSINESS
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK THROUGH
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. THEIR WORK
OF REGIONAL BANK BUSINESS
TRAINING CENTERS WILL SUPPORT
THE UPSKILLING OF THE REGIONAL
WORKFORCE TO MEET THE DEMAND
FOR JOBS IN THE FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY SECTOR. DURING THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
IN THE EMERGING AND DOMINANT
INDUSTRY SECTOR IN THE POST OF
IT NINETEEN ECONOMY. IN
ADDITION AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WILL FIND NON PRIORITY
ETP'S SECTORS SUCH AS
HOSPITALITY RETAIL MINING AND
AGRICULTURE. SECTORS THAT DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR AGENCIES SUCH
AS NONPROFIT HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION AND GOVERNMENT. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL ALLOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
STRENGTHEN OUR PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL EMPLOYERS FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR HARD WORKING
FAMILIES INCLUDING. UPSKILLING
OF LOWER WAGE EMPLOYEES AT THE
DANCE OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
ABILITY TO OBTAIN HIGHER WAGES.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HAS
TREMENDOUS STATE WIDE SUPPORT
FROM THE BUSINESSES WE SERVE AS
EVIDENCED BY OUR ABILITY TO
GATHER OVER FIFTY LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IN LESS
THAN EIGHT HOURS. CURRENTLY
EIGHTY 47-57 HAS OVER EIGHTY
FIVE LETTERS OF SUPPORT PLEASE
VOTE YES ON AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER. UNDER WE ALSO
ELDEN DAVID WITH THE CENTER FOR
CUTS TREE AT OAK COLLEGE ON THE
LINE MISTER DAVIDSON IF YOU'RE
READY PLEASE BEGIN YOUR
COMMENTS. MISTER MODERATORS
MISTER DAVIS ON THE LINE.
VICTOR DAVID SENATOR ON THE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
I THINK WE CAN MOVE TO ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ME
JUST A FEW MOMENTS. SEMESTER
SHARE I HAVE A MESSAGE THAT.
MISTER DAVIDSON IS JUST GETTING
ON THE LINE. SO MAYBE IF WE GO
BACK TO HIM AFTER OTHERS THAT
ARE HERE CERTAINLY.
YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NOT A CIGARETTE THREE TECHNIQUE
COLLEGE DISTRICT CALLING INTO
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JOHN STALLMAN AND I AM A
CITIZEN OF BUTTE COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT AB ONE FOUR FIVE SEVEN
AND REQUEST VOTE YES PLEASE.
LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN MELBOURNE I'M WITH THE
SANTA CLARITA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
A BI FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT OKAY. HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
IT FRANK GREAT TEMPERATURES YOU
KNOW COLLEGE BOARD OF TRUSTEE
MEMBER. WE'RE CALLING TO
STRONGLY RECOMMEND SUPPORT OF
A. B. FOURTEEN. FIFTY SEVEN
ACTIVE UNTIL AND REYES. LINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I AM FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HI THIS IS JOHN FOX BROWN
CHEEKY COMMUNITY COLLEGE I AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT- EIGHT
FORTY FIFTY SEVEN AND WOULD
RECOMMEND A YES VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL. LINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AM FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE. LINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT STANDARD DISCO I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE CHAFEE
COLLEGE IN TAX CENTER AND I
WOULD LIKE CHECK IN STATIC WE
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. LINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
THE WINDOWS AREN'T AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION OF A TOASTER
DURING NURSING AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BELL AND AFTER YES.
THANK YOU. FOR NINE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR DEBORAH MCCAIN BEING
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AT DHAKA
COLLEGE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AN APT FOR YOUR YES VOTE
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. MADAME
MODERATOR MAYBE WE COULD CHECK
IN WITH MISTER DAVIDSON TO SEE
IF HE'S BEEN ABLE TO JOIN US.
MISTER DAVIS SENT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE AND THEN. ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE OPEN YOUR LINE THANK YOU.
DAVID WE HAVE. THREE AND
RAFFERTY AND. HELLO. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MIND FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANNE RAFFERTY AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR AT THE COLLEGE FOR
CONTRACT EDUCATION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF OUR
LOCAL EMPLOYERS. AND PLEASE
VOTE YES. BONTA MODERATORS THAT
EVERYONE IN THE QUEUE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
TIME YEAH THERE'S NO ONE OUT
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RACES HERE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THERE WE GO WE NEED SOME. IN A
CHAIR YEAH. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. I WISH TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL FOR WHICH I AM A
JOINT AUTHORS. I AM PROUD TO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
ABOUT THIS ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. THAT WILL COORDINATE ON A
REGIONAL LEVEL PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
BUSINESSES TO HELP UPSKILL
WORKERS FOR EMERGING CAREERS.
THESE TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
WILL HARNESS THE POWER OF
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRAINING PROGRAMS SO THAT
WORKERS ARE TRAINED FOR JOBS IN
THE CENTRAL SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMY. AS WE THINK OF WAYS TO
RESPOND TO THE WORKFORCE NEEDS
IN THE COBIT AND POST CODE WITH
THE ERA THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
WILL ENSURE THAT WE ARE
LEVERAGING OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THAT WORKERS
ARE READY FOR THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW. I WOULD REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT JOB
CREATION SPILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES I BELIEVE
NOW IT'S TIME TO HEAR. WELL I
JUST WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT
HAS NOT SPOKEN IN SUPPORT YET.
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK THE
MICROPHONE SAYING NOBODY WE CAN
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT A MODERATOR WE
HAVE BOBBLE LANTER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION ON CONFERENCE LINE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. GO AHEAD
SIR. HELLO THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M BOB LANTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION CBA AT THE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THAT IS
THE COORDINATING AND ADVISORY
BODY EPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
FORTY FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS. THAT'S
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. LOCAL WORKFORCE
BOARDS WORK CLOSELY AND HAVE
DEEP CONNECTIONS WITH BOTH THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL AND
CONTRACT EDUCATION CENTERS
LOCAL BORDER SUPPORTIVE OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO SHORT TERM
TRAINING AND ARE THEMSELVES A
BUSINESS LED SYSTEM THAT
STRIVES TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
BUSINESS. HE TO BE A SUPPORTER
SUPPORTIVE OF GREATER ACCESS TO
TRAINING AND GREATER SYSTEM
COURT NATION ESPECIALLY AS OUR
STATE ECONOMY RECOVERS.
UNFORTUNATELY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN IT'S NOT A BILL THAT
WORKS TOWARDS EITHER OF THOSE
OBJECTIVES THE BILL'S LANGUAGE
TO ENHANCE REGIONALLY FOCUSED
STATEWIDE BUSINESS TRAINING
CENTER NETWORKS DID NOT PROVIDE
ANY SPECIFICITY AS TO HOW TO
MAKE TRAINING MORE READILY
AVAILABLE. AND IT'S MANDATE OF
REGIONAL SKILLS MAPPING GREAT
AND OTHER SILENT PLANNING
PROCESS BUT DOES NOT COORDINATE
WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
WILL LEAD TO CONFUSION BETWEEN.
BUSINESSES AND JOBSEEKERS. AB
FORTY FIFTY SO. THE DECIMATED
THE COPS STABILIZE MILLION. IN
A TIME OF UNPRECEDENTED
FINANCIAL STRAIN. RATHER THAN
PUT THE MONEY TOWARDS TRAINING
THE BILL LAST OR COORDINATION
FROM THE LABOR AGENCY. ETP THE
STATE WORKFORCE BOARD AND GO
THERE. AND EXPENSIVE AND
POTENTIALLY PROLONG PLANNING
PROCESS. IN ADDITION THE BILL'S
REQUEST TO CREATE REGIONAL
SKILLED MAPS RECREATES THE WORK
WITH THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
BOARD HAS DONE TO REGIONAL
PLANNING AND A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE REGIONAL CPP CONSORTIA
HAVE ALREAD UNDER GOD. WHICH
THE STATE. HAS ALREADY INVESTED
MILLIONS AND- WE RECKON THAT
NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE THE
TICKET. IN RETRAINING. AND
SUPPORTING BUSINESSES AND
CALIFORNIANS AFFECTED BACKUP IN
NINETEEN. HOWEVER EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THE BILL
THAT IS SET UP TO SPEND MORE
MONEY ON COORDINATING EFFORTS
AND GETTING MONEY OUT THE DOOR
FOR SUPPORT SERVICES AND
TRAINING. THIS TIME OF CRISIS
IT'S AN EXPENSIVE MISTAKE TO
MAKE. THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING OUR
CONCERNS. THE YOU SIR AND
UNDERSTAND WE ALSO OF ANNA
ELDORADO WITH THE EDGE
COALITION ON THE LINE. MS
ALTERADO PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M NOT ABOUT
ABOUT WHAT THE CALIFORNIA AT
COALITION ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ADD TO THE STATEWIDE
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WE ECHO THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT THE W. A. WITH
REGARDS TO ADDING NEW
REQUIREMENTS OF EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL IN ADDITION TO
CONCERNS AROUND THE NEED FOR
MORE SHORT TERM. CREDENTIALS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALREADY
OFFER SHORT TERM TRAINING
PROGRAMS BOTH ARE REGULAR
CREDIT AND ON A CONTRACT
EDUCATION BASIS WE KNOW THERE
IS URGENCY AROUND ENSURING
PEOPLE CAN GET BACK TO WORK WE
ALSO KNOW THAT LONGER TERM
CREDENTIALS HAVE BETTER LABOR
MARKET PAY OFF. WHAT
IMMEDIATELY AND OVER TIME
INDIVIDUALS WHO OBTAIN A LONGER
TERM CREDENTIALED GENERALLY ARE
ABLE TO RETAIN JOBS AND EARNING
FAMILY SUSTAINING INCOME.
THEREFORE WE BELIEVE THERE
NEEDS TO BE MORE CONSIDERATION
OF THE MIX UP CREDENTIALS
NEEDED DURING THESE DIFFICULT
ECONOMIC TIMES FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE I LOOK FORWARD TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. OF
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES THANK
YOU. THANK MADAM MODERATE. IN
ELSE ON THE COMP LINE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WISH TO BECOME
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO WE DO HAVE ONE PRIOR.
I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S OPPOSITION
OR NOT YOU WANT ME TO OPEN THAT
LINE SURE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FIND FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THAT G.
SUITE ON A COMMUNITY MEMBER-
BOB YOU COUNTY NINE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TELL ME
JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE COLLECT
THE LINE NUMBER FOR THEM.
LINE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS JORGE SILVA AND
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE OF
THE SEQUOIAS TRAINING RESOURCE
CENTER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN I ASK
YOU TO VOTE YES. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JOSE AND I
A CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY- MY
NAME SAYING I AM I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NETWORK FOR
MANUFACTURING INNOVATION FOR
NAPS ADVOCACY GROUP THAT
SUPPORTS MENU INNOVATION AND
DURING THIS COBIT. SITUATION WE
NEED ALL THE SUPPORT THAT WE
CAN GET SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND TO
VOTE YES THANK YOU. MATT A
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
REMAINING THAT WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THIS
TIME THERE IS A NOTING Q. THANK
YOU ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE. I
TURNED. NEWS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORK SILVA YES I FIND THIS BILL
TO BE VERY CREATIVE ESPECIALLY
AT A TIME WHERE WE HAVE TO HAVE
IT AND START LOOKING AT WAYS TO
TAKE THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS AND GET THEM RETRAIN TO
SECURE EMPLOYMENT BUT IF YOU
COULD EITHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RADIUS OR- CERVANTES OF ONE OF
YOU WOULD ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
SO IT JUST STARTED TO. IN
RESPONSE TO THE OPPOSITION AND
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
ON WHETHER THIS PILOT PROJECT
DUPLICATES ANY EXISTING
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY IN THIS
REGARD I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT LANGUAGE RECENTLY AMENDED
INTO AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH STATES. THAT THE PILOT IS
TO AVOID DUPLICATION AND TO
SUPPLEMENT AND EXPAND ONLY
WHERE NEEDED TO ME EMPLOYER
TRAINING NEEDS. ANOTHER CONCERN
THAT WAS RAISED WAS THAT THE
REGIONAL SKILL GAP MAPPING IS
DUPLICATE DUPLICATIVE OF OTHER
MAPPING EFFORTS. IN THIS REGARD
I LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
FOLLOWING FIRST THOSE PLANNING
EFFORTS ARE NOT SCHEDULED TO
BEGIN UNTIL NEXT SPRING SECOND
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS REQUIRED
THAT DATA USED TO IDENTIFY THE
REGIONAL SKILL GAPS BE SHARED
WITH LOCAL REGIONAL WORKFORCE
BOARDS. HAVING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CENTERS FOR EXCELLENCE
UNDERTAKE THIS EXAMINATION OF
THE COVE IN NINETEEN ACADEMY
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER CAN
SERVE AS A JUMPSTART. TO FUTURE
PLANNING EFFORTS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND
TRAINING PARTNERS AGAIN AND
THOSE WERE A COUPLE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I WANTED JUST TO.
TOUCH ON TODAY. I'M OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU THERE IS A MOTION ON
THE BILL BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS WHAT. IF THE
CONSULTANT CONTROLS THE EXACT
LANGUAGE FOR THE MOTION- IT'S
UNUSUAL IT'S WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED IN.
OKAY THAT IS THE MOTION WILL
YOU KEEP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ABSOLUTELY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WITH RECOMMENDATION THAT
SAID IN A MOMENT SPEAKING CARD
AN- CHAIR CERVANTES HI. YOUR
CERVANTES I'D VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM. VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHECK OUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHANT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PORT SILVA HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK SILVA.
THAT GO TO SEVEN ZERO AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS THIS COMMITTEES
ADDRESS.